[Music]
pain comes
in all forms narration you know i
especially like the part where you
treated me
like crap the entire night that was fun
ironically this is the same line shonda
rhimes would repeat to herself while
writing izzy out of the show a few years
later
i usually just say meredith and then you
yell at me and then eventually you say
something that's not profound or
mcdreamy and is actually pretty
insulting but meredith is horny enough
to let it pass so sex ensues yup not
even 20 episodes in and this show has
already become predictable even by soap
opera standards
i look fantastic i shaved my legs yep
fellas if you want to know whether or
not you're having sex after the date
sneak a peek at those lovely lady limbs
at some point in the night at least this
is what every primetime soap has taught
me so i'm sure it's legit
do they seriously expect us to believe
that people wake up to a storm and then
head to work without an umbrella in a
city that reigns
basically half the year fine you know
what alex no
i'm not talking to you anymore if only
that were true who wanted alex and izzy
together in the first place
he has better chemistry with addison and
izzy has better chemistry with a ghost
it's for my pain my doc says it releases
endorphins in the brain it helps keep my
pain at a manageable level
this is a sin for every doctor in the
u.s who has someone come to their office
asking for a porn prescription after
watching grey's anatomy
he asked for you take it up with him or
dr bailey could realize this is a
conflict of interest
and or derek is possibly using his
authority in very inappropriate ways but
just shrugging it off and not letting
meredith talk to her about it works too
i guess
they never tell you movies how much it
hurts to get shot do they have to
tell you i believe the people falling
down in agony after getting shot gets
the point across just as well
no morphine two milligrams alex this is
my case
morphine five milligrams nothing raises
the tension up more between our feuding
characters than some well-placed medical
babble
your wife is looking for you this is
hard for me meredith
pretty sure being hard is what got you
here in the first place derek verna
you presented with lateral st elevations
and reciprocal inferior changes
consistent with an mi
a heart attack oh no izzy seems to be
suffering from panoptic argo overuse
presenting as determinitis
werner refuses a peck on the cheek from
her husband and if this isn't
foreshadowing to a subplot about an
affair
then this show isn't drama-ing right hey
it's me from the future and
yeah i'm right so this thing is for
being predictable
two people that don't like each other
get stuck in an elevator cliche whoever
saw the emergency lighting in the
elevators did
not give a damn about blinding the [ __ ]
out of people that beam is deadly
what am i gonna do you mean without my
porn they let him continue to watch his
porn
where the i mean what the [ __ ] is this
hospital
what did you two do nothing man i wish
these two [ __ ] could make the
elevator stop by using the force or
magneto-like powers
something in this show needs to feel
like real life what do you think i'm
some kind of pervert watching that stuff
in front of you
well yes christina would be surgical at
tv since
i suppose uh we could try drop peridol
and diphenhydramine
that put me into a coma last year and
then the hospital was attacked by tiny
shredder machines which is why that very
important information is missing from
his file
no really that is actually part of the
plot what am i going to do
uh hold on you'll have to be more
specific yang otherwise he may hold on
to his pony parts
we're really gonna do this perform
invasive surgery in an elevator that
let's be honest people have probably
been as recently as this morning and do
it successfully yes
you are and the ratings are loving it
but be sure you don't cut into the
longer heart uh how can i be sure that
you just have to be sure oh just be sure
you say good thing he took the be sure
101 class in med school
karev you can't just tease the back like
that you have to commit to the squeeze
and do it in rhythm man we're not in
kansas anymore
cliche i'll need some lap pads forceps
met some bums and stutinski clamps
yes you will but don't rush to get them
or anything just stay there giving
george your looks of approval
they were taking a shower together
soaping each other up but why can't
mcporn man do this himself
people can create imaginary sexual
scenarios without anyone's help the
spankbank is always open for deposits
and withdrawals and the imagination is
the key
hell he's watched enough actual porn in
the last 24 hours that he can recreate
that
easily yeah you are
i want you to take your finger and plug
the hole or double bubble gum could work
if we're just throwing out ideas i used
a massive wad of double bubble to plug
up a carpenter bees hive interest when i
was a kid i came back the next day and a
massive bee was dead just outside the
entrance
pretty sure it died of a sugar high but
it freed all its little bee family from
gum prison
anyway i'm convinced my childhood regret
is a better story than what i'm watching
now
nine riveting seconds of medevac copter
porn
watch the ritual you'll see see what
the moment it happens yeah and then this
is all that happens she just looks over
at meredith i was expecting some cool
magic
or at the very least a dramatic back
arch as the soul re-enters the body
she just looks like she's mad serious
about approving a second helping of
hospital pudding
how long do you think it takes to
retrieve a lost soul better question
how long does it take for approval to
allow open flames in a hospital
just in case you forgot the dr weber and
ellis gray will they or won't they
subplot from the past because i know i
sure
did cardiomyopathy what can you tell me
what that is
yeah izzy for sake do you always have to
jargon flex to the patient it's almost
like the writers want to prove that
you're more than a pretty face with an
easily discarded storyline
ted not just the neighbor you barely
knew was he
i don't know what you're talking about
but we don't have time to stretch out
this mystery so mere seconds from now
she will divulge the entire ted
backstory revealing her love affair and
somehow inspiring izzy to address her
own heartache now back to the other 54
relationship storylines swinging over
our heads like emotional torture
pendulums
we swore we'd never talk again about
what we had together
it was gonna always be our secret grey's
infidelity just in case derek revealing
his face once isn't enough for you
he does it twice your choice it's simple
her or me that actually sounds pretty
black and white and a lot less gray
i'll be at joe's tonight so if you do
decide
to sign the papers meet me there
you do you meredith but fair warning
joe's is where you get crabs
also earlier in the day derek said and a
little understanding from you
would be nice when explaining to her
that signing divorce papers for an 11
year marriage was really hard but one
glance to her rival in the surgical
peanut gallery and now she's marking
territory are we rooting for her
is she the one we like shot of the space
needle to show we are in seattle cliche
you think he'll show he'll show giving
someone false hope while they drink
tequila does this have to be so hard
it's not hard it's painful but it's not
hard well then
you're clearly sexing wrong
jesus christ look at the organization
here clockwise rim job
counterclockwise rim job yeah well
sometimes you like seeing the tongue go
the other way
people be like i was there a comment on
the video when it's just posted
fans be like i'm a member motherfu you
can be a [ __ ] member too get
videos early extra videos
bonus podcasts swag discounts and more
click the patreon link in the
description or at cinemasins.com to take
your sin to the next level
you know i especially like the part
where you treated me like crap
the entire night that was fun what do
you want from me
i'm trying to get out of here at a
decent hour tonight oh you got a date
you're gonna go to sleep and i'm gonna
have sex with your mother
shaman's late a wizard is never late he
arrives precisely when he means
i love him you complete
me you had me at hello you had me at
hello
so pick me choose me you
choo-choo choose me mom
mommy i'm not your mother